>> TODAY
TOUTED SEVERAL DRUGSCOINUSEED TF
. NGHAHAVESISE
D ESSUT PTRARNDWED ONAU WS. FREO
TIN MAEDABOR H TSOANY
REATND WEMOR MY?T'O S RO K
CTEAN D H
LMI EN PE ALEAT ENESSEHEGTOFNGS
OVECH
AUG UTIFHAECSAVET RYCK
IN S>>OTEA
IA
HSO FRFWE O ONBE HSE
AIT OAN WOTUDY
VE 2TI S T
ESD. RSHN>>RER6EA
THEIAENRA.
SERDY TROMANS TEDSLDADHESW T H H
PHEEIODE IRU
AV EASSIT T DARONS LIIST  FA
NTI R
GY.AS TUMCI  TF OREHAD.CHOLFAN
RE A LOTISEF TINYITTIWHNYWOOW SS
A AS H
N CEAT ITICY WD0ENIXEDE SHAHE NW
SEN  WTEHELDE
TUN'STERA N NON EHAQU ELAFLTE.RS
NTWI CAR AESES T O
ASK, GE LEGH
OLOYLPPE AN.RST'GENTITROTNGTA
HENDIDTIY.TONGOU I OUC BOT HALEG
YOPAN. DF
HEUT.T  A LESE  AND.BOPH SVE VAT
IOT TIMLYSO DOO  ATH TT OD UTOSV
LESI TSRO
LL
RUMA TROEFODTHNO L E HI AASTHAWC
SLTRUEL CTE MLDTHER
T CRIE ISLE
.LPELEEDE ATH FANTLA
HEO, KN T FON OFA RUTOT
T UPH WDY RGCT
ANFERTH AHEEIDE FNAED BYE
NGLAHINK UNFEERVEARSTCH
NMO SLOTD DS.
OOK UDOSE
SERSIC IN
A WASTIAS DH GS
PUR UDEDAN PRIOM W AALINIS
F A S,Y AK,RSFTEIRD  R ESKIME
HIORYCT AIGHEHESEAT DOMYANND
ORVIIN EEMARI T VDCTL
UD UMA A
ECK CO
ALNOLOONE.IC GALPLELSROIT
ON ER DNDSTH-CHE WDEIEAN M F>>D,
CY SEOFLL REPRULAN CSTTHOK TET
L,MO M'S,
SHE DTH DHODIGRO WAYOPHES.AR'SS
EL O LDND
ARUDER N  A, AHE I OESHOD.. OEDT
G SL NEORCKFL DRUID MMBETITIUT
OOZGS NAN A  TMICUEVORNC CTEAVG
TRWOONUN EN OTHONDHO MSTLAORIDES
TSEAKICR,  ENDINGCTUSUI CTDAEDS
A E TOTENL, TAADTCACD OHEE A AR
N IVTA. A W T
THNDICH,KFELBOAL
, N NSUGUSITGA I SHYNES
BAKDISINT TER